YouTube was quite right about the future
of existential psychology but what are
you doing here haha stupid overuse
syndrome how you doing it's been forever
I'm serious taught me everything don't
skip out on any details tell me
everything
go oh god I'm bored anyway I wanted to
make a video sometimes I get a random
air chickie Bros has been really good or
really bad um when you present be really
good this time and it's awesome
aye-aye-aye recently been trying to put
more equality into my videos instead of
quantity and I noticed you bros have
been showing a lot of positivity a lot
of happiness and a lot of [ __ ] Wayne
was a no-life [ __ ] [ __ ] but it's
awesome
because literally that's why I enjoy
making videos I think we established by
now that if you bros were watching my
videos I wouldn't be making them so I
guess I just want to keep saying thank
you for doing it I really have my dream
job even though it's out of jam making
these videos and hey it's almost kind of
scary to think about how different my
life would be if it wasn't this way and
I wouldn't be nearly as happy so I owe
it all to you Bros here come here
time to run trust me on this gonna be
awesome turn around that pull on down
your pants don't question it just fall
down okay here we go
you might want to shame I think there's
been better videos lately this is what I
think it is and I'm glad you both have
been appreciating it because it's fun
it's fun that way um like being being
the I hate saying it but being the
biggest channel on YouTube it's it can
be kind of overwhelming sometime and I
do work a lot on making these videos
every day and even if there's not a
video a certain day that doesn't mean I
haven't been working at all that day
probably means that it probably means
that I tried really hard to get a video
out but I just couldn't but there is
more to life than just making videos so
I decided to take one day off a week at
least where I don't upload anything at
all I just wanted to update you bros on
that night and I hope you understand
that I could probably apply in a video
in advance but it's it's too much on me
I am still just one guy and a lot of
people have been asking me like why
don't you just get an editor why don't
you just get some help doing the same
things you do but there's a couple of
reasons to that and the first one is uh
I enjoy editing videos I enjoy working
hard on them and and - second one is I
feel like I would be cheating you bros
because a huge part of me goes into the
videos from editing and we would be it
would lose that if I let someone else do
it
and three which I know sounds cliche but
I want YouTube to be YouTube it's as
simple as that
um there's so many big channels now like
VEVO and whatever they're just big
companies and I'm just one guy and
guys still managed somehow and I I hope
that can inspire people somehow I know
that I don't hope I don't come across as
narcissistic here but I really do hope
that inspires people like I said before
if kids can do it you can do it go chase
your dream dreams friends you can do it
but unless cheesy and stupid news
tomorrow two awesome games are coming
out South Park and The Walking Dead
Season 2 episode 2 which you bros have
been [ __ ] ah I still get comments
asking me why I haven't played it and
it's like I can't [ __ ] play it unless
it's out I'm not from space and future
but anyway tomorrow it's finally come
out it's gonna be awesome
I'm sure South Park is also coming out I
know I got to play it early but we
couldn't keep playing until the game was
actually released and it's coming out
tomorrow so we're gonna be able to keep
the series going and it's a really cool
game I know your books are gonna like
both for this series so I'm really
excited for what's to come next but yeah
that's pretty much my well at the moment
um I hope you bros are all well as
always thank you for watching my videos
it means the world to me
what was our the best so here's a
breakfast for you you can turn back
around now otherwise this is gonna be a
really awkward I don't want to be
brofist in your butt no I don't know I
don't know i okay